thank you for coming today we are very
pleased to welcome you to the J Irwin
Miller symposium is drawing dead we
think the Dean for his thoughtful and
invaluable direction as well as the
Miller family for their generous support
of events like this our work on the
symposium has also been enriched by
critical feedback from many of our
colleagues and we owe them our
appreciation Georgia Knight and I began
work on this symposium about 18 months
ago and we were meeting to discuss the
challenges we faced as practicing
architects and drawing educators we and
many of our students no longer drew in
the traditional sense the sketch the
draw an act of conception was vanishing
and with it in many cases the
intelligence and visual literacy that is
part and parcel of the making of
drawings and of architecture we found
ourselves in ambiguous space over the
last 15 years there had been a marked
shift and the means and methods of
producing architecture during that time
architectural drawing move further into
the digital realm despite the increasing
prevalence of digital production however
drawing was still defined by traditional
methods and a traditional model of
practice architects dealt with lines in
space and those lines were printed on
paper as normative architectural
conventions that we'd been used to as a
common language line detail plans
section and so on recently however
drawing practice has begin to yield to
myriad tools and modes of thinking and
representation Rhyno Revit digital
projects and many other programs have
allowed architectural drawing pad
practice to evolve in radically
different ways the line is seated ground
to surface and volume form exists as a
three-dimensional construction of a
reality in space yet it is
simultaneously the real the built object
in digital space
and something ineffable inaccessible a
simulacrum of sorts and during this
latter period these recent years there's
also been a remarkable dearth of writing
and thinking and discussion and drawing
practice in the late 80s and 90s drawing
discourse was abundant in energetic
writers such as Robin Evans were the
standard bearers for rigorous
consideration of the role in history of
drawing drawings by Sterling Moore
Phasis Mariah's Eisenman Hadid and many
others used drawing to think and
articulate up lemak and the
architectural drawing consequently it
was a means of communicating a larger
epistemology and the drawings moved
beyond representation to layer dynamic
tools that expressed a powerfully held
thesis the drawing as a set of
principles was in line with historical
traditions derived from Vitruvius
through the Renaissance and Palladio to
Corbusier ARCA Graham and many others
now we find drawing practices
ill-defined and under stress hand
drawing is surely decaying yet one can
argue digital practice is also under
duress
the line is gone and with it the rigour
of the drawing as a means of
investigation Thom Mayne has described
this condition as a lack of resistance
the line as a means of questioning and
challenging assumptions has been
dissolved and consequently the
interrogative and critical role of
drawing an architecture was withering
leading Georg and myself to ask if
drawing was not dying if not dead
so helping us to engage that question
and many others like it our speakers
today and tomorrow the first panel today
the voice of drawing history meaning and
resistance seeks to explore foundational
questions of drawing practice for our
discussions this evening Sir Peter Cook
will explore a wide range of visual and
conceptual territory that drawing
engages tomorrow we take on digital
practice and
more directly with our session burning
bridges in the morning and in the
afternoon session we will debate
drawings essential critical energies and
the conference will close with Mario
Carbone his talk on the opacity of
architectural notations the
presentations and subsequent
conversations promised to be divergent
and stimulating and of course critical
to the success of this symposium is our
audience you we appreciate their many
different viewpoints and we're anxious
to engage all of you and discussion
particularly since so many of you have
travelled very far to get here and have
a lot to offer the discussion following
the conclusion of each speakers
presentation at the at the close at the
end of every speaker will have a
moderated discussion and at that time
we'll bring in the moderated discussion
with the with the audience questions and
participation and we encourage you to
talk and engage in the debate that were
that we've started so on that note I'm
very pleased to welcome cami brothers to
the podium
professor Brothers has a BA from Harvard
Radcliffe a PhD from Harvard and is
currently an associate professor at the
University of Virginia
professor brothers has been the
recipient of numerous prizes and
fellowships in her book Michelangelo
drawing and the invention of
architecture was awarded the Charles
Rufus Mori Brook award as well as the
Alice Davis Hitchcock book award
professor Brothers also has a
forthcoming interview with James
Ackerman that would be published soon
and is working on a new book Giuliano
desengaño in the ruins of Rome her
research and publications focus on
architectural drawing artistic exchange
around the Mediterranean Renaissance
theories of architecture and literature
and the interaction between the
practices of painting architecture and
sculpture cami brothers
I'll just wait for the first slide okay
great and the mic is you can hear me
okay yes thank you so much is the mic up
now you can hear me yes okay okay first
of all thank you so much to it for the
introduction and to the organizers for
the opportunity to to speak here it's
very exciting for me to have an audience
of architects for the historical
research that I do for centuries
function has dictated the conventions of
architectural drawing despite the many
ways in which the history of art and
architecture intertwined this is a
fundamental divide artists drawings have
changed tremendously over time not only
in subject matter but also in every
aspect of their approach to
representation while a striking number
of qualities of architectural drawing
have remained constant since at least
1500 if not before today I would like to
explore what architectural drawing might
do if its functional constraints were
loosened the question arises in part
from my fascination with a set of
experimental architectural drawings made
in the last decades of the 15th century
in the first decades of the 16th before
the conventions of plan section and
elevation were established but it also
comes very much from the present moment
the presence and transformational power
of digital rendering is an inescapable
fact of architectural culture today the
preparation it requires can easily be
seen as competing with training in
traditional drawing methods as if the
two modes were in direct rivalry with
one another and giving rise to the sense
that drawing is at risk but seen from
another angle the advent of the computer
frees up drawing for other purposes no
longer bound by the need for precision
or direct involvement in the
construction process architectural
drawing might loosen its bound
even reopening a dialogue with
figurative modes of representation I'll
try to make my case today by first
exploring what it was the early
draftsman were striving towards goals
still unmet and then by considering in
brief some of the promising ways modern
and contemporary designers have used
drawing for purposes beyond the
construction document what I hope will
emerge from these efforts are the
outlines of an alternative history of
architectural drawing rather than focus
as many studies have on the origins and
developments of the conventions we know
now we know today planned section and
elevation I will consider experimental
modes that existed outside these
categories and accomplish different
things my argument will be that it is at
the margins of 15th and 16th century
practice the modes of drawing that had
no immediate imitators that a possible
future of architectural drawing can be
found first I should suggest what is
alternative about this narrative that I
am presenting studies of Renaissance
drawing in the past have typically been
concerned in a retrospective manner with
how things got to be the way they are in
other words how to draftsman arrived
through fits and starts at our thigh
agonal drawing and how and why did they
reject perspectival drawing the unstated
premise is typically that these
conventions were in some way inevitable
and are in all ways superior the
underlying historical paradigm of this
dominant narrative is that things get
better over time in specific terms the
assumption is that our thigh g''l
drawing was a notable improvement over
the haphazard and imprecise modes of
drawings that came before my own premise
is different I will argue that
architects such as Giuliano desengaño
and baldessari Perutz II demonstrated a
range of possibilities for architectural
drawing that have been little explored
since in a series of exploratory
drawings they mapped out a territory
between the traditional confines of
architectural drawing and the
conventions of painting conceptually
their drawings are defined not by the
will towards abstraction but by their
inclusiveness of visual facts and
experiential conditions typically
omitted for example the passage of time
the quality of light and the experience
of moving through a building all of
these belong to traditional concerns of
painters and in fact seems that both of
architects took inspiration for the
works work of painters who had come
before them and I should say this is
basically just an evocative by a
backdrop suggesting kind of how
architects drew monuments it's not I'm
not talking about it directly some of
the achievements of 16th century Italian
draftsman have had an extremely long
afterlife in the history of architecture
architects
such as Antonio Dustin gala the younger
and Palladio whose drawing is shown here
employed plans section and elevation in
a way that established a pattern that
would be followed for many centuries of
course in part through publication as in
Pilates for books
I will focus instead on aspects of
architectural representation that that
were ignored by later generations these
in particular these concern that
experience of a building through time
its conceived in two main ways
first there is the perception and
understanding of an existing building as
a thing that has passed through history
but that simultaneously lives in the
present and second there is the sense of
how a building is exterior and interior
may be perceived and experienced in
relation to one another while the
unusual modes of representation employed
by Sangalo and fruits dear Trish
traditionally criticized as being by
historians as being fantastical or
painterly I will suggest that they could
succeed in conveying types of
information that are typically neglected
I will allude only in passing to
Giuliano built architecture but is
crucial to understand that his buildings
drawings of Rome were a form of research
and he often drew ancient buildings
analogous to those who was on the verge
of building so just to give you a sample
of his work here's Santa Maria della
Casa D in Prato Padua Kayano
the villa Palazzo Strozzi in Florence
and Santa Maria Maddalena de pasión
Florence while I will characterize
Giuliana's approach in various ways most
broadly I want to suggest that in place
of the singularity of moment and view
privileged by perspective his drawings
demonstrate an interest in temporal
simultaneity and multiplicity of
viewpoint these represented these
representational modes reflect a desire
to render the experience of ancient
architecture rather than only it's
double its abstract qualities the terms
through which Julianna saw the past owed
much to Petrarch who in the 14th century
had described the status of the poet
caught between the reflection on ancient
the ancient glory of Rome and a drive to
create new works in particular Julianna
took up the Petrarchan conceit of what I
will call double-time corresponding to
Patrick's feeling that he was living in
two historical moments simultaneously
among his peers Giuliano was virtually
alone and is concerned for the temporal
quality of monuments many architects
such as here chronica took things from
the ruins
they took measurements they took forms
and most worryingly they took physical
materials sometimes in the form of line
stones
sometimes as prize SPO Lea although
architects would often note the original
location or Frank of a fragment or
monument they typically showed little
earn or no concern for its existence as
a physical artifact Juliana by contrast
engaged empathetically with the ruined
monuments and these are two pages from
his book
his book of drawings the Codex Barberini
made between roughly 1465 and 1516 and
held in the Vatican Library he conveyed
even enhance their statuses historical
monuments that had experienced the
passage of time and the onslaught of
weather one of the most elaborate of
occasions of double time occurs in
Giuliana's drawing of the so called
crypto ball be an arch structure reduced
to a single now reduced to a single arch
in the ghetto and also notice the
Porticus minutiae
it's another view and this is one of the
few details where you can see sorry of
Giuliana's drawing where you can see it
correspondence to that present Monument
while recording its measurements and
remarking on its the technique of oh
sorry and remarking on its technique of
marble revetment he employs a dramatic
group graphic means to demonstrate the
effects of time on the surface of the
building and on the ruins arrayed under
the arches thomas green has written of
the act of disinterment undertaken
metaphorically by Petrarch and later
humanists unearthing the literary
remains of antiquity so as to resurrect
them in Juliano's vision as in reality
for architects the disinterment is
literal the seated figure and I'm sorry
this was quite a it's a little hard to
make out the seated figure here seems to
be perched on the edge of an abyss a
crack in the marble terrain his nudity
and the toga worn by the standing man to
whom he turns and gestures suggest that
these are meant to be ancient figures
temporarily then Juliano's drawing works
at a minimum of two levels the condition
of the monument emphasizes the passage
of time since antiquity
while the presence of the nude and toga
wearing figures suggests that the
historical moment is not quite over
Guiliano's inscription also suggests the
Doublemint nosov time he writes that it
is it is said that this is was the bath
of Marco
gripa and human sees how the Romans
convey covered their walls with a marble
veneer while indicating that the
monument occupies Piazza Judea where
today there are many butchers forcefully
evoke in the present the first clue
about an interpretation of the drawing
may reside in the choice of monuments
included in the background in the middle
of the left arch is a variation on the
mausoleum of Augustus here Augustus was
best known among architects of the claim
that he had found Rome a city of brick
and lefted a city of marble Giuliano
fimA ties his materiality by
representing the left and right arches
differently with the left adorned and
the right exposed Juliana represented
the Porticus as a facade and thus
transformed it retrospectively into a
model for his own designs of palazzo
kaki seen especially in the window
details the possibility of this
transformation is already suggested by
the way the facade of the palace in the
background echoes echoes the composition
of the Porticus the message directed
towards a patron could go something like
this
Augustus turned a city of brick into a
city of marble and using this economical
technique you can do the same exactly
how is suggested by the annotation about
revetment and less directly by the
palace in the background the shrubbery
and its roof suggest that the building
is supposed to be ancient but it is a
Roman clearly a Roman Renaissance style
Palace not unlike the Concha Lidia the
doubleness of time Giuliano presents
here had precedents within the visual as
well as literary tradition Tuscan
paintings of the 14th century often
employ architectural divisions as a
means of conveying distinct sequential
temporal moments in a single frame for
example in st. Nicholas brings a child
back to life by Ambrogio Lorenzetti at
the effete see from 1332 we understand
the arc of a child's murder and revival
through the division of architectural
spaces these pictorial devices were
crucial for the illustration of
miraculous events on the part of Saints
whose intercessions could most
dramatically be shown by representing
both the moment of the tragedy and its
aftermath
saved by the Saint more than has been
acknowledged this tradition continued
through the 16th century in paintings by
Filippo Lippi and Pontormo for example
and so what I'm referring to is just the
kind of complex uses of space in these
paintings by Lippe and print Ormeau in
relation to narrative 15th and 16th
century painters so frequently represent
placed biblical figures in contemporary
settings that we have almost ceased to
see them for their strangeness a
prominent example includes Gillan diodes
representation of contemporary Florence
and the Chapel of Santa Anita and of a
ruined arch in the nativity scene shown
here
similarly familiar was the allegorical
placement of ruined monuments in the
background of nativity scenes as in this
painting by Botticelli
to demonstrate the collapse of paganism
and the triumph of Christianity Giuliano
drew from all these traditions and
provided his viewer with the thus
providing his viewer with a key to the
interpretation of his images even when
the figures were made into minor players
were removed another component of
Juliano's interest in time occurs in his
attempts to render the sequential
experience of seeing a building's
exterior and interior as if these
occurred in a single moment in this case
is temporal and spatial investigations
overlap in the Codex Barberini he
represents two temples side by side one
at Ostia and in the forum watiam in rome
he includes multiple representations of
round temples but these are unusual for
the amount of information he includes
his inscriptions his inscription which
says how the temple whose plan is drawn
below appeared inside and outside
modestly States the impressive ambition
of the drawing
when that no established convention of
representation has yet achieved this
idea of simultaneous views also had a
rich pictorial tradition especially in
14th century siena in the context of a
painting sorry in the context of a
painting it had several obvious virtues
it could convey more narrative
information in a smaller amount of space
by placing a building within an urban
setting but also allowing the main event
in allowing the main event to take place
inside a spectacular example of the
inclusion of information about interior
and exterior simultaneously occurs in
Ambrogio Lorenzetti x' presentation of
the temple of 1342 he provides a full
sense of the materials and architecture
of the temples exterior as well as its
interior even Giuliana's concede of
using a ruined building to expose its
interior had already been employed by
this generation of painters Pietro
Lorenzetti had already used a similar
solution in his frescoes at Assisi
illustrating the life of st. Francis
showing a church in just enough
disrepair so as to expose the crucifix
within the inside nystagmus of buildings
was an important issue in renaissance
design
Juliana's representations of his design
for a church at san giovanni de field
and tini which is here and as compared
with his drawing of the mausoleum of
Theodoric and Ravenna suggests the
direct implications have his
representation of ancient spaces for his
design practice another realm in which
this problem of inside and outside is
crucial is anatomy in this or in the
arena of dissection in which the entire
purpose is to understand the interior of
the shell that is our visible body
simultaneous representation brings
tremendous analytical advantages
Leonardo's da Vinci's innovations in
this his representation of the hue
whoa womb and skull combining a
cross-section in the case of the skull
combining a cross-section a perspective
drawing in a bird's eye view have
features in common with his
architectural drawings as well as those
of Giuliano anatomical study had none of
the constraints of architectural drawing
and that it was not being used to build
or measure anything only to understand
well Giuliana's most adventurous
drawings concerned existing monuments
baldasar EEP roots these graphic
imagination flourished in response to
the challenges of representing his own
designs among his most extraordinary
drawings is his reputation of his design
for st. Peter's which is simultaneously
a splayed perspective it's one detail
another detail what I have called an
inside-outside drawing and a perspective
view of the plan it also contains a
temporal idea in that it suggests a
building in the midst of construction
and these are the piers kind of half way
going up in this regard it is more
complex even than Juliana's drawings it
shows in it shows the design both in the
stage of conception the plan of
construction the view of the piers being
erected and of execution the section of
the back wall it resembles in some
regards Pietro Lauren Betty's Nativity
of the Virgin in the museo della paura
then voila in which the space is splayed
along two axes so as to get in very many
types of information simultaneously
other architects such as this anonymous
draftsman of the of the morgan codex
attempted similar things but none with
such virtuosity and it may have been the
complexity of the drawing of brutes
whose drawing that limited the extent to
which it could become a model for later
draftsman an another impressive sheet at
Oxford which proposes remodeling the
Church of San Domenico and San
bourtzi has taken a lesson from the
Sini's painting
painters in the virtue of displayed
perspective as a way of including more
information it's just one comparison to
seen his painting painters and another
for example prutte sees sorry Lorenzetti
x' fresco of the last supper in the
lower basilica of san francesco to see
see shows the viewers the details from
both the exterior and interior of the
building what people are eating the roof
and the floor details most remarkably he
includes the representation of a de
jacent room were has seen both
peripheral and essential to the main
event is taking place the cleaning of
plates by two servants with the aid of a
small cat and dog his use of slate
perspective allows him to represent not
only the central scene but also to
suggest a new sociological insight even
at the last supper
someone has to wash the plates Brewed
sees oxford drawing allows the viewer to
see into each of the four bays almost as
if standing immediately in front of it
he distorts the perspective both along
the horizontal axis as well as the
vertical axis with the effect that what
we are actually able to understand the
effect that we were actually able to
understand the internal volumes of the
design much more comprehensively what is
striking about Pruett C's case is that
he clearly knew the rules of perspective
drawing and of orthogonal drawing
extremely well he was a master of
Shannara fie a painter and designer of
stage sets all of which depended on his
skills in these arenas this is one
example of his stage set designs which
clearly shows that he knew how to do
perspective properly if he wanted to he
was also the author of an extremely
precisely impressive section through the
pantheon in Ferrara
so when Kurt see chooses to bend the
rules he does so not out of naivete but
from the point of view of someone with
enough mastery of the conventions to be
able to recognize their limit
and move beyond them in addition to
these relatively finished drawings
fruits he also used similar techniques
in his design sketches in these tiny
drawings and with a fuse with a few
strokes and delicate use of wash he
deftly suggested the presence of light
and the relationship between interior
and exterior volumes and I should say
this detail that I'm showing here is
about an inch wide the drawings I have
been discussing were made at a time when
the canonical modes of architectural
drawing were information their
experimentation took place not at the
margins of the profession but at its
center but by the end of the sixteenth
century many of the conventions we now
know had become predominant and fewer
architects worked outside them according
to many accounts this is where the story
ends once the plan section and elevation
had taken root in the newly
professionalized practice of
architecture
they remained remarkably stable over
centuries during with which everything
else about the profession of
architecture changed to some extent this
claim may be true but I would like to
suggest that the painterly exploratory
mode exemplified by Giuliano and fruitsy
has continued alongside these
conventions well into the 20th and 21st
century this alternative tradition
because its function is less clearly
defined has been for the most part
either neglected or denigrated in a
manner parallel to the classification of
Juliano's drawings and has been testicle
these have been dismissed as paper
architecture I would argue instead that
these unconventional drawings
particularly when seen in relation to
their Renaissance and antecedents
perform a crucial role in exercising the
architects imagination and the viewers
perception briefly I would like to
outline some of the functions that
drawing outside conventions has served
for modern and contemporary architects
first there is what Italians called the
Primo penteado
or the first idea this is probably the
most familiar type what we often think
of as the cocktail napkin sketch well
few examples of this survive from the
16th century reflecting its lowly status
they've in some cases risen to fetish
items in contemporary practice as
exemplified by Frank Gehry's office what
does it say about architectural culture
today and its contradictions that an
office whose entire practice is made
possible by advanced software identifies
itself on its web website exclusively
through a quick hand-drawn sketch and
this I'm sorry for the kind of small and
not high-resolution quality of this but
it's directly from its their website
with this category there's a there is of
course much variation and an interesting
example is Peter zoom tour whose preemie
pants Yeti themselves have what I would
call a painterly quality akin to
Michelangelo's and similarly both
architects were using materials not
typical for architects but more typical
of painters namely black chalk colored
chalk the second category is the
dreamscape
in other words fantastical architectural
creations never meant to exist in
reality but a evocative of the
architects imagination exemplified by
the work of shower and head yoke scolari
and many others many of whom present in
this audience at least in the case of
shower room what looked outrageous and
fantastical when he drew it in the 1920s
and 30s as in this example has become
almost commonplace and certainly
achievable the third category is the
travel sketch was which is certainly at
risk in the era of the pocket camera it
may be that modernism's discomfort with
a past and the idea of emulating models
has made the practice of drawing earlier
buildings seem like a strange nostalgic
thing despite the fact that the
Corbusier Kahn and many modernist heroes
were devoted to it and here I'm showing
one of Kahn's quite extraordinary
drawings of Venice or paintings or
little watercolors of Venice which is so
clear and Giuliano and prudes
drawings as well as cons and here's
another example and I which wish could
be recovered in contemporary
architecture is a sense in which is a
sense of the way in which the process of
looking and drawing something in the
world is not or prop not properly
slavish but completely engages the
architects imagination
finally there are design drawings in
this group those that interest me most
parallel Peru sees drawings in pushing
architectural representations or in
sorry in pushing representational
conventions the work of zaha hadid shown
here and preston scott kohn is important
and it both seemed to have begun with
drawings but at a later stage engaged
digital rendering as a way of extending
the discoveries they made on paper in a
different mode but resembling other
drawings by prudes see archons design
sketches and their indication of how a
space would be felt and I thought this
was an interesting and kind of striking
comparison this is one of con studies
for this synagogue and the fruit see
sketch I showed earlier there's another
observation I would like to make about
contemporary practice in the role of
drawing I referred in my title to
discussions of Renaissance drawings and
the idea of experience what I mean by
this has something to do with how the
visitor inhabits moves through perceives
and remembers architecture it
corresponds to some degree with the
concerns of phenomenology in many
regards digital rendering has achieved
amazing things on this front mapping the
precise effects of light on a surface at
a given moment of the day and how it
changes over time producing dynamic ways
of moving through a virtual building and
so forth there's a factor that runs
deeper than this which has to do with
what neurologists are discovering about
how our minds and bodies engage
empathetically with what we see when a
ballet dancer watches a ballet being
performed his or her muscles actually
engage in response to the movement scene
although similar studies have not been
done of artists I would argue that when
an artist or architect looks at a
handmade drawing or painting his or her
physical memory of drawing is engaged in
a way it is not in looking at a digital
rendering no matter how replete
may otherwise be with information in my
mind at least the future of
architectural drawing has much to do
with the extent to which it can move
beyond the representational of
conventions that have defined much of
its past when not only need one need
only think of the analogy to the state
of painting today of course painting has
been declared dead many times over but
it under undeniably survives changes
moves forward and transforms and
whatever death nails may have been
sounded they have never been wrung by
the avatars of digital transformation
the computer will not kill the canvas
and the mere idea seems absurd so why
when painting and architecture have for
much of their histories been intertwined
is it is it that in this regard there is
a stark divide of the capacity of a
digital or risk of a digital takeover of
many of the traditional provinces of
architect and not of the painter I would
suggest that it is because no one while
no one disputes that the work of a
painter is the work of imagination
architectural drawing has for much of
its history been burdened with the long
list of other requirements and
expectations as a result of the new
conditions introduced through digital
rendering it is possible that drawing
might be liberated from these
constraints and able to more fully
embrace the imaginative possibilities
than have always been part of its
function but sometimes suppressed I
would also argue against a triumphalist
view of history that involves this kills
that if we look at Antonio das angle as
copy of fridge' condos 1511 edition of
Vitruvius of the met we do not find any
evidence that it slowed his desire to
draw but quite the contrary
he drew all over it correcting and
annotating and amending it in dialogue
and this is really in response to that
another historical idea of of technology
changing things which is the advent of
print it is this kind of relationship
that I see is most fruitful hybridity
and dialogue between the traditional
form of working of
traditional form of working and new
technology what I ultimately hope to
suggest is that by distancing
architectural drawing from its
conventional roles within the profession
rolls now better performed by software
it is possible to imagine its
independent speculative future I would
like to briefly return to my primary
subjects Sangalo and Peruzzi and to the
link between perception and imagination
in their drawings what was the
significance of the drawing of drawing
the monuments of Rome or existing
drawings and Genting buildings in
general for the practicing architect
typically this is envisioned in banal
and mechanical terms the architect
learns a set of precedents that could be
reused at will but in Giuliano and
prutte cease drawing at least the
challenge of drawing complex Roman
buildings forced them to develop graphic
means of representing them if it is true
that you design what you can draw then
it follows that having learned to draw
these spaces opened up the possibility
of incorporating them volumetrically and
spatially into their designs in this
light perception and representation can
be understood not simply as modes of
documentation or as ways of collecting
precedents but as active and creative
modes of training the imagination and
impressing certain memories upon it
using them and to train the memory to
fuel the imagination thank you
Cammi thank you for a very thoughtful
and provocative talk
the only thing constraining us in our
conversation today is time and they're
switching to the next one for us so with
that we must rush headlong with her and
into our next speaker
Deanna Prather pithre bridge is emeritus
professor and also visiting professor at
the of drawing at the University of Arts
London she was also professor of drawing
at the Royal College of Art from 1995 to
2001 where she launched the Centre for
drawing research the first doctoral
program and drawing in the UK professor
pethor bridge is also an artist writer
and curator primarily concerned with
drawing in her 2010 book the primacy of
drawing histories and theories of
practice was published in June 2010 by
Yale University Press in the US and UK
and examines the importance of drawing
is a significant practice in Western art
history from the 15th century to the
president it is a seminal and beautiful
piece of work professor Prather [ __ ]
thank you for the introduction and thank
you also for inviting me here as a non
architect I have to say that I haven't
been into a review and I haven't been
into a design studio for at least 12
years so I'm very much an outsider but I
also want to congratulate you on the
exhibition of drawings made by which is
upstairs around the Solaria exhibition
and I was so impressed with it they're
so intense it's such a good program here
so I would really like to congratulate
you as I'm talking within the historical
section of this conference I have framed
my not always entirely solemn views on
aspects of architectural drawing and my
critique of contemporary visualization
images with a brief contextual preview
of drawings from the 1980s the time that
I was teaching drawing at the
architectural Association in London and
writing for range of architectural
journals the following images
I'm afraid are probably pretty familiar
staff but perhaps I approached them
slightly differently from the viewpoint
of a generalist drawing scholar Peter
Cook Christine Hawley and arca Graham
with their plug-in cities and visions
are benignly mechanised techno
environments had set the scene for a
British love in withdrawing and
futurology in the 1970s but the reasons
for the graphic explosion in the next
decade were also profoundly economic
many of today's celebrity architects
from this generation spent years in a
graphic wilderness drawing thinking
teaching and inventing if not building
although the 20th century had witnessed
a total breakdown of media distinctions
and artistic hierarchies drawing as
dream abstraction or manifesto
remained the only possible possible
alternative for out-of-work architects
at the time perhaps it was this enforced
period of a sort of Kantian
transcendental idealism that has made it
so difficult to embrace so difficult for
some of us to embrace the
instrumentalist view of the present day
that drawing is an entirely pragmatic
and mechanistic activity of no
particular aesthetic value or
consequence the fine monochrome drawings
of James wines for best products built
between 1972 and 84 were potent in
different way I think the drawings is
just me making a kind of bumpy noise
that's fine that's just heavy breathing
is it thank you
I apologize okay
the drawings were potent in a different
way from the actual warehouse buildings
dependent on surrealist humor the
traditional skills and I think these are
most beautiful drawings and they work
with very traditional skills of finely
manipulated pen in ink textures or
loosely applied charcoal strokes those
in the image on the right
deliberately mime the directional
application of tarmac that was to swamp
and roll over the drowned vehicles all
of these suggests more subtle readings I
would suggest then the performative
aspect of the actual buildings as verbal
visual puns and built-in possibilities
this seems to be an interesting and
potent mismatch and I'm not saying as a
critique just as a comment
normally a building is the most complex
and accretionary state of a
developmental process that involves
drawing but the 1970s site where houses
with single state enactments or
performances arising from very rich
drawings had continued themselves to
participate in other narratives and
histories the parallelism and font ality
of these drawings as in most of the dawn
examples which I will be showing in the
next slide
are the embedded signifiers of
architectural ISM and the inescapable
referentiality of architectural graphics
and I say this because of course so much
final drawing is not necessary
referential in the same way the slide
rule and right angle are implicated
within these drawing board images in
spite of their conceptual hierarchy as
well as the dominating gaze of
perspective to apply a phrase from
Roberto Perez Gomez or other kinds of
projective geometries this might seem a
very obvious comment but the drawings of
this era were offered on an open market
so to speak and were competing with the
art world offerings of conceptual art
and post-modernism that had stood all
such structural frameworks the drawings
of the later M Raymond Abram melded
colored pencil and watercolor in
evocative and slightly melancholy images
evoking discourses of archetypes
archaeology rituals firmly frontal if
laterally indeterminate they usually
depended on a horizont on a horizon
division as a form of philosophical
plimsoll line with buildings and carved
spaces articulated above and below it
this is the ground if I may possibly use
such a loaded term and I think of dally
bhava silly every time I say ground so
that's why I'm saying I'm saying it
apologetically this is the ground that
traditionally separates applied
perspective construction from the space
of pure mathematics as laid out in the
watercolour drawing by Friedrich Gilley
who was a mentor of Schinkel there is
very much the same age a geometric meta
space traditionally occurs below and
beneath historical perspective drawings
shaping and shadowing the pictorial
application and this of course is in
textbooks not in the early
Renaissance are examples we saw earlier
the 1980s pong farm for excavation that
challenges the certainties of a ground
line was noticeable in many iconic
drawings had also doubled as manifestos
at this time Gaetano Pesci visiting New
York buried a church below a vacant lot
between city towers and vault apitla
buried into a tentative and ambivalent
ground plane in this very subtle but
contradictory image Emilia Amba's carved
out a song called sunken Chapel
reminiscent perhaps of the Ethiopian
rock churches of lalibela in his iconic
cooperative Mexican American grape
growers project Santa Rosa California
1976 I think therefore I'm suggesting by
showing these buried these cutout
drawings that there's a haptic
correlation between the textural
responses of a feeling hand which
happens in these drawings and the
representations that appear to sink into
the fibrous paper surface to carve out
spaces and this hapticity of course is
something that has been replaced in
computer drawings as we'd be looking at
later I contrast this particularly in
these drawings with ubiquitous shiny and
reflective surfaces that I'm going to be
very critical of that we'll see later
econometrics and isometrics were most
commonly the generators of strict form
and supposedly as we all read about
objective spaces in the 1970s and 80s
and yet when you look at this selection
of images they could engender the most
romantic evocative and inventive in a
way pictorial renderings by very diverse
architects carrying out very diverse
programs again I draw your attention to
the predominance of the ground plane and
its desire for embellishment something
again which I think has very radically
changed Exxon emetics were also the
generators are boldly abstract
elevations and sections
free of shadows but encompassing
textures and elaborate facades
superimpositions and lovingly if very
laborious ly rendered in the very
determinant medium of colored pencils
and these were favored at the time I
think because they maintained the formal
linearity of traditional drawing tools
they could be laid down and they could
be very pleasurably crosshatch could
take hours and hours to really enjoy
making a drawing with a ruler and they
discrete coloration and textural
inflections could simultaneously
participate in other forms of color
coded structural systems as you're
particularly Co of course in the
Stirling drawing without a change of
register
that's quite complex but what I'm saying
is the the colors are both about the
colors that are going to come into the
facade they facade colors they pre
determining colors but they also color
coding in very many other structural
ways so these drawings had looked quite
simple or actually quite complex in
terms of overlaying representation and
diagram are also two very different
things in drawing are therefore United
and unified two dimensionally as a set
of equivalences that would directly
influence the decorative geometries of
the built form in encompassing the
potency and transparency of axonometric
projection for generating a powerful new
modernism I do believe it with the force
of Daniel liver skins drawings that blew
apart the static concepts of 1980s
architecture possibly forever he wasn't
alone in this but I think his drawings
were very important in this event by
moving away from what he termed the
stabilized frameworks of drawings as I
quote the fixed and silent accomplices a
building and construction into these
compressed fragments which always defy
orientation and his drawings themselves
are very often shown in different ways
too because they are not about a
particular orientation
Libba skin not only enabled his own
the current buildings to challenge the
pull of gravity but he inspired an
architectural revolution for many
including students and I'd like to say
that I think it could be said that the
move away from traditional or focalin
orthogonal try be itis that has so
radically marked architecture of the
last two decades I believe was a graphic
invention waiting for computer
technology to invigorate its hubristic
propositions the micro mega strong's and
the more romantic drawings that followed
I don't have the date of the other
drawing on the screen have of course
also since inspired many other non
architects such as the American
Ethiopian artist Julia Maria to by the
mid-1990s when I was installed at the
Royal College of Art Iran drawing
studios and I regret to say they were
more inspired propositional cabarets
then structured lessons totally ignore
kkuk but sometimes fun where animation
architecture industrial design and so on
people attended from all across the
school by this time the cad revolution
had already exploded other forms of
computer imaging however and i'm making
the distinction in this I'm probably
very ignorant between the
straightforward care that works out
where you work out your drawing and
between the kinds of imaging processes
you're going to use at the end product
and these were still very much in a
state of slightly painful technical
evolution this implied that potentially
design historians would be able to
construct a historiography of computer
styles and be able to date the types of
imagery that had fed back so
transparently into the architecture of
the day and I hope I'm not being unfair
but I do feel this is a key building it
looks exactly like what wasn't then
being invented the absolute joy we have
been able to construct tubes and so on
on computers and I feel it it fed back
there was a two-way passage should we
say I do feel it's conditioned in some
way by the technological limitations of
imaging systems of the day
a historical analysis however depends on
the potential of digital expansion
beyond the founding computational models
that have shaped the conventional
perspective of space and constructional
principles of image making in 1997
Alberto Parrish Gomez had written that I
quote computers have contributed next to
nothing towards restructuring the
hegemony of Panoptix space and proposing
a more meaningful and participatory
urban space the and I'm quoting him
again the tyranny of computer aided
design and it's graphic systems can be
awesome because it's rigorous
mathematical basis is unshakable it
rigidly establishes a homogeneous space
and is inherently unable to combine
different structures of reference and
I'm quoting him from 1997 and showing
these images to say not all that much
seems to have changed the lower images
on the slide derives from the 1990s but
are not substantially different from a
design project in the year 2000 which is
a curious little creature sitting in the
desert and it's actually a tent I've
discovered with a sort of built in
something rather that keeps you warm at
night or even the sorry or even the
imagery of my next slide on the other
side of that is an interactive
PlayStation game which has just issued
it's just come on the market now and it
requires teams of soldiers and engineers
to defend the ark built as a
self-sustaining city of the future but
now falling into disrepair there's some
message that the future can also
disappear the static frozen frontality
and slippery curves of this range of
cliched digital imagery to me acts as a
mask or blanket on difference masks
originality and effect emotion
not to mention building type
programmatic
in tension spatial social environments
or philosophies of style all the
thousand-and-one determinants that shape
architectural expression and it seemed
to me I'm really curious that that
little scheme by Eva Jarek nur had
suddenly discovered Victoria Rock and
London in a state London has never been
and never will be let me make it clear
in spite of my mock melancholy use of an
image by Michelangelo which I started
the lectures I am NOT for one moment
going along with the proposition that
drawing is dead I don't believe it for a
moment far from it I believe that
architectural form which is always
driven and sustained by drawing of some
kind is particularly in vibrant and
inventive at this time and it said
wonderful and interesting and event of
age we living in albeit often cited in
inimical urban context and I don't just
mean that the wonderful buildings
everybody's building our inside inimical
urban context I feel they very often
create a very public problematic urban
context I think there's often a huge
conflict between marvelous architecture
and urban sites but we can't have time
for that I am however making a clear
distinction between those forms of
drawing and diagram which are associated
with invention critical analysis
communication problem-solving
development and so on whether hand or
technological difference or
technological driven and make a
difference between that and the use of a
stale kind of heavily restricted cyber
imagery that is only purports to
represent the built product and it's not
dealing at all with any of the kind of
ideological facts which lie between a
work and its representation there is no
longer useful nomenclature for these
kinds of promotional images although
they used to be called renderings or
presentation drawings and it's
seems to me that this topological lack
is a minor but nevertheless a
significant casualty of Tecna philia in
the past the conceptual and physical
acts of drawing and design development
would produce seriously serially in a
mutually determined timeframe and
employed codified we know this all
codified and designated modes of graphic
production marked by breaks and
interruptions allowing for invention and
dialogue such acts are now embodied
within embodied within a seamless
supposedly seamless and continuous mode
of production
sometimes curiously at odds with the
fragmented paradigms and that they
purport to explore of course this notion
of seamlessness is an illusion in a
chain of technological shifts from the
implement employment of electronic
sketch pads to card workstations to the
expert accessing of a successor of
successive number of sophisticated
programs including the means for
manipulating moving imagery which is
often part of the skills needed for
presenting business buildings the task
of designing and construction
engineering now involves a whole chain
of experts and specialists employing
different hardware and software all of
his activities and records need to be
correlated
the plug-in connectivity of all these
diverse systems is modeled on the
unshakable and I really do question this
valorisation of the integrative world
wide web as the cosmic paradigm we all
subscribe to it we don't question it
this means that nothing whatsoever can
escape the continuously masticating
digestive tracts of the omnivorous cyber
mouth a notion of course that had
procedure and previously belonged to
hell
with the inclusion of what were
previously differentiated modes of
thinking drawing into such a
universalizing system architects are
left and this was said by the previous
speaker architects are left with very
few non mechanical drawing options apart
from those rapid first thought sketches
that museums of course are very eager to
collect and my example of such a drawing
by tom main indicates how extremely
informative such generative sketches are
in allowing us to understand the
thinking and development of a design
concept nevertheless the cult of the
sketches are collectible can also
function in a very different way just as
British artist Damien Hirst belatedly
saw the commercial imperative of post
production sketches to promote his
Duchamp pian inspired betweens of sharks
and what have you pickled in
formaldehyde so for some architectural
practices sketches now function as a
species of logo identity intended to
humanize huge projects such sketches
might not really be about autograph or
origins of ideas but they set out to
proclaim the human eye and hand
concealed within the computer which has
now as predicted by Pickler become a
prosthetic extension of the body for
most architects by contrast the slide
shows freewheeling sketches of different
dates by Frank Gehry whose public
personas were said by the perb
speaker is so closely identified with
hand drawing these drawings follow in
the long tradition of the conceptual and
generative first sketch as formally
indeterminate even in create speedy
careless fuller Corrections of
pentimenti as the hand follows rapidly
evolving ideas immaterial contingent
open-ended because issues such a scale
or materials or structural determinants
or social programs have not yet been
finalized in these small sketches we can
just follow in this particular selection
how the building gradually clarifies and
fleet frees itself from the mass of
swirling and gestural lines in which it
is entrapped the difference between the
fragile sketch and the immense
complexity of gary's final project could
not be greater in this context taiked
technology SiC signifies a magical and
transformative means that appears to
fill the unbridgeable void between
concept and build realization of course
Gary's practice moves in real time for
more gradually between low and high tech
through degrees of crushed paper -
constructed 3d models etc and drawings
at aloud translations into build form
and via super software which I believe
we'll be hearing about tomorrow
the enabling and transformative
sophistication of the technology implied
by the Gary office means that the firm
can now even build buildings that appear
to have all the contingency seeming
fragility lack of closure and
determinacy a premie pensiero first
thought sketches the small autographic
sketch for centuries understood as the
very antithesis of fixed form material
and scale while suggestive of such
possibilities er has actually become
identified with its instantiation
and possibly it could be argued
identified but not reconciled if I knew
anything about philosophy I think I
would assume that all sorts of
ontological and teleological
propositions are set into a state of
unease by these very extraordinary acts
technologies endeavours to undermine
physical laws outsiders as well as
within the phantasmagoria of virtual
reality have of course been a common
visual trope of post-modernism and I
refer you to will also 2005 building the
Center for cognition culture and
computation everywhere over the world
they were getting together all of us
computation and culture which functions
as a space for visual art students in
association with digital workshops and
his scribble sculpture was of course
developed in 3d from a CAD model of
course nothing as simple as a linear
scribble can remain in cyberspace it
immediately slides into a potentiality
of seamless and endless transformations
in other media times and contexts the
1990s obsession everybody was a
deconstructionist in architecture in
those days but the obsession with
Jacques Derrida's endless chain of
meaning deferral I think he I found he
find visual at least cyber real counter
counter parts if high technology has now
served to establish an almost
inconceivable differentiation between
sketch and built outcome or a chimeric
identification of hybrid states both
inside and outside cyberspace it should
not be forgotten that this was not so
within traditional building paradigms
and this drawing by Erich Mendelsohn one
of very many for the Einstein tower
signals a clear phenomenological
relationship between the world practice
curves of the drawing hand and the
taught arched forms of the final built
project in Potsdam the determinedly
autumn
graphic drawing with his variable brush
lines arising from Mendelssohn's
trademark curved horizon appears to
prefigure in some way the actor forms a
three-dimensional plasticity with all
the Verve of a sculptor and Wendell's
Mendelssohn we know didn't sustain this
embodied isomorphism in his later works
and I included the previous drawing in
order to contrast it with the promise of
haptic interface effects offered by
digital sketch pads according to the
blurb for SketchBook Pro I quote because
it makes use of the pressure sensitivity
features away come tablets tablet PCs
and iPhones
it can help artists sketch and create
effects similar to traditional materials
and I've deliberately shown the
advertised visuals for this because the
type of broad and fibrous sketch marks
drawn on the screen are presumably meant
to project evidence of the X facility of
natural hand pressures natural hand
pressures made possible on gesture based
use interface however rather than
suggesting to me that drawing is a free
and open ended activity that can be
adapted for any kinds of purpose and
future State this quick fix advert
projects a standardized multi-purpose
grotesque
imagery of manga cartoons that inhabits
the entire visual graphic world from
computer games to animation and this is
a hegemonic type of graphic imagery that
is also an invading visual virus
simultaneously controlling and
undermining powerful cyber systems it's
a ride thought that in such virtual
games and animations built form is
usually only set up in order to be
trashed exploded and destroyed while
everybody runs around killing each other
cyber aggression is as careless I would
say with architecture as it is with the
lives of avatars and in support and also
defeat of my own argument I've included
images from a very
little animated film robots brixton made
by student at bartered school University
of London which recently got a prize at
the Royal Institute of British
Architects and it deals with rioting
robots attempting to rebuild destroyed
urban spaces and dysfunctional social
housing today under its declamatory even
triumphalist drawing which probably
could have been made after the event
celebrates the geometrical potency of
the temple this beautiful temple as
inflected by the gestural imperfections
of his Swift hand except for the central
bisecting vertical and horizontal this
emblematic inscription has little to do
with the haunting textural and spatial
subtleties of the build temple above and
below-ground but it certainly informs us
about the structural and formal potency
of simple geometric juxtapositions I
suggest that when all drawing designing
processes happen within the virtual
confines of screen and infrastructural
programs caught up in the relentless
onwer drive of seamless computing those
ruptures that are very necessary for
decision-making become enlightened and
weakened this drawing however reminds us
of the power of the drawing as punctum
or halted moment in a developmental
continuum perhaps this is why under has
returned to a curiously old-fashioned
collage style drawing methodology in
this sketch for the shanghai poly
theatre and the drawings of models were
recently shown a gallery GA in Tokyo
last year the great sweeping circular
holes that are torn into the prismatic
theater complex to function as an
amphitheater Terrace and foyer recalled
the an architecture of Gordon
matta-clark and his situationist work
conical intersect 1975 below where a
circular viewing hole was cut through
one of the about to be demolished
buildings on the hudiburg in Paris the
juxtapose work above on the screen is a
piece by the English artist Richard
Wilson for the Liverpool Biennale in
2008 and I couldn't unfortunately find
his drawing but it's very very simple to
the today under drawing and he also used
Trude lines over photographs very old
fashioned means of drawing for this
building stylistically very closely and
I wondered about it and I thought about
and I decided perhaps this dive
deliberate crassness of means employed
by somebody with all the subtlety of
under his means that drawing now it's
been important to become an indexical
sign of those brutal scars of
interventions into the holistic fabric
of existing buildings and we near the
end non are not bad on time this slide
posits the difference between an
extraordinary expressive and gestural
drawing of hands ha line from 1962 where
one can virtually feel the action of the
outstretched arms of a crucified figure
marking the horizontal plank of a
cruciform shape and a recent project
where again such cantilevered forms are
being employed the tentative nature of
the little project sketch on your left
sorry relates maybe I wondered why why
is his drawing so change why is it so
tentative now and I thought maybe it's a
nervous expectation of the blanketing
effect of computer visualizations in a
technical age that I've referred to
before and that I've Illustrated on the
right after all this is an image that's
put out by Holland's office drowning by
computer present-day visualizations are
so hybrid that it's often difficult to
know where the digital photography with
its ability to be endlessly touched up
and smoothed over is simulating
constructed computer simulations or vice
versa and perhaps it is this hybridity
that defies the evolution of a useful
critical discourse which is what I'm
promoting in this presentation I end
with two arbitrary selective
visualizations for competition projects
and I chose competition projects because
in at least you know that this is clever
computing images and not doctored
digital photographs there are gathering
clouds in the neoclassical Schinkel s
perspective vision on the left but not a
single cloud disturbs the frozen
perfections of the Cartesian spaces of
contemporary England or Abu Dhabi
clear-cut against their cloudless skies
and safe in the unitary climate of
cyberspace and the timeless embrace of
perspectival ISM the obligatory water
reflections could be interpreted maybe
as ETL ated references to a more modern
semiotics of reflexivity but probably
not thank you very much
Deanna thank you that was terrific the
two speakers in we already have a lot to
think about and we must continue and
engaging the haptic and the conceptual I
think we're pleased to welcome you honey
people asthma professor plasma has been
engaged in architectural product and
graphic and design plight Town Planning
since 1963 and runs his own
architectural office in Helsinki while
serving as acting professor of
architecture at the Helsinki University
of Technology professor pol asthma has
designed exhibitions of Finnish
architecture planning and visual arts
and is the author of numerous articles
and lectures on cultural philosophy
environmental psychology theory of
architecture and arts in various
countries professor pol asthma's recent
books are the thinking hand eyes of the
skin architecture in the senses and the
most recent work is the embodied image
imagination and imagery and architecture
professor plasma
good afternoon I feel a bit moved
speaking in this space after 19 years
when I was teaching one semester at the
Yale University
I have entitled my talk drawing with the
mind pen hand eye and brain hands a
generic organs characteristic to Homo
sapiens but at the same time they are
unique individuals
the vivid movement of the contours of
Omri Marty's colorful paper cuts obtain
a special meaning after having seen a
photograph of the aging artist warming
his aching finger joints in the feathers
of domesticated pigeons or drawing on
his sickbed on a sheet of paper on the
wall
with a charcoal attached to the end of a
long bamboo stick Andre was in ski the
core BCS long time assistant describes
his master's hands poetically and
suggestively then I would let my eyes go
from the face down to his hands
I would then discover the Corvis yet it
was his hands that revealed him it was
as if his hands betrayed him
they spoke all his feelings all the
vibrations of the inner life that his
face tried to conceal hands that might
have thought the hands that one might
have thought la Corbusier had drawn
himself with that trait made of
a thousand small successive traces that
seemed to look for one another but that
in the end formed a precise and exact
line that unique contour that outline
the shape and refined it in space hands
that seemed to hesitate but from which
precision came hands that always thought
just like he did in his thinking and on
his hands one could read his anxiety his
disappointments his emotions and his
hopes hands that had drawn and were to
draw all his work works of art and
architecture extend the hands to hand
both through space and time when looking
at Ronda Dini pietà I can feel the
passionate and wise but already feeble
hands of Michelangelo he's known to have
worked on this very piece a few days
before his death the work of great
architects also invite the imagined
presence of the architects figure and
hand as the architectural space scale
and detailing are unavoidable
unavoidably products and projections of
the makers body and hand we can touch
the hands of Michelangelo and Palladio
as well as Frank Lloyd Wright the
Corbusier and Alvarado through their
buildings
the hand of the master is always the
more present the greater the work we use
the notion of the hand carelessly
without much thought as if its essence
were self-evident Frank R Wilson
neurologist and writer explains the
multiplicity and mystery of the hand as
follows bodily movement and brain
activity are functionally interdependent
and synergy is so powerfully formulated
that no single science or discipline can
independently explain human skills or
behavior the hand is so widely
represented in the brain the hands
neurological and biomechanical elements
are so prone to spontaneous interaction
and reorganization and the motivations
and efforts that give rise to individual
use of the hand are so deeply and widely
rooted that we must admit we are trying
to explain a basic imperative of human
life we consent certainly conclude that
the hand speaks to the brain as surely
as the brain speaks to the hand
Wilson regards the hand even beyond its
physical and neurological significance
significant sees as an essential
constituent of the story of human
intelligence and its gradual evolution
any he writes any theory of human
intelligence which ignores the
independence of hand and brain function
the historic origins of that
relationship the impact of that history
on developed developmental dynamics in
modern humans is grossly misleading and
sterile yes we usually think that our
hands merely deal with the concrete
material world but some theorists
attribute to the hand a significant role
even in the emergence of symbolic
thought there are quite impressive
theories about language originating in
the hand in addition to the tool a
skilled practice of drawing or craft
combines imagination with the hand every
exercise of drawing or craft projects
determined intentionality and an
imagined vision of the completed task or
object at hand Richard Sennett makes two
basic arguments about the interaction of
the bodily actions of the hand and
imagination quote first that all skills
even the most abstract begin as bodily
practices second that technical
understanding develops through the
powers of imagination
the first argument focuses on knowledge
gained in the hand through touch and
movement
the argument about imagination begins by
explore exploring language that attempts
to direct and guide bodily skills the
draftsman and roar need to develop
specific relationships between thought
and making idea and execution action and
matter learning and performance self
identity and work pride and humility the
draftsman craftsman needs to embody the
tool or instrument internalize the
nature of the materials being used and
eventually turn him herself into the
drawing or product either material or in
material in his book Berger on drawing
John Berger points out this
identification of fusion of the maker
and he's her product in the craft of
drawing each confirmation or denial
brings you closer to the object until
finally you are as it were inside it the
contours you have drawn no longer
marking the edge of what you have seen
but the edge of what you have become
while drawing amateur designer and
architect is not focused on the lines of
the drawing as he is envisioning the
object itself and in his mind holding
the object in his hand or occupying the
space being designed this is a sketch by
Alvarado during the design process the
architect occupies the very structure
that
the lines of the drawing secondarily
represent as a consequence of the mental
transfer from the actuality of the
drawing or the model to the material
reality of the project the images with
which the designer advances are not mere
visual renderings they constitute a
fully imaginative optic and
multi-sensory reality the architect
moves about in the imagined building
however however large and complex it may
be as if walking in a building and
touching all its surfaces and sensing
the materiality temperature and texture
this is an intimacy that is surely
difficult if not impossible to simulate
through computerized means of simulation
and modeling while working on a drawing
one concretely touches all the edges and
surfaces of the designed object by the
tip of the pencil that has become the
extension of one's fingertips and the
inner world of the mind belt in and
round to use beautiful the beautiful
notion of Reiner Maria Rilke the hand I
mind connection in drawing is natural
and fluent as if the pencil were a
bridge that mediates between several
realities and the focus can be
constantly shifted between the physical
drawing and the non existent object in
the mental space that the drawing
depicts sketching and drawing are
spatial and haptic exercises
that fuse the external reality of space
and matter and the internal reality of
perception thought and mental imagery
into a singular and dialectic entity as
I sketch a contour of an object human
figure or landscape I actually touch and
feel the surface of the subject of my
attention and unconsciously I sense and
internalize its character in addition to
the mere correspondence of the observed
and depicted outline I also mimic the
line written with my muscles and
eventually the image becomes recorded in
the muscular memory sorry in a muscular
memory in fact every act of sketching
and drawing produces three different
sets of images the drawing that appears
on the paper the visual image recorded
in my cerebral memory and a muscular
memory of the act of drawing itself all
three images are not mere momentary
snapshots as they are recordings of a
temporal process of successive
perception measuring evaluation
correction and revaluation a drawing is
an image that compresses an entire
process and it uses a distinct duration
into an image a sketch is in fact a
temporal image a piece of cinematic
action recorded in the graphic form this
multiple nature of the sketch it's
layered exposure as it were makes me
remember each one of the hundreds of
sketches that I have made around the
world during my fifty years of traveling
whereas I can hardly
recall any of the photographs that
thousands of photographs that I have
taken because of the weaker embodied
recording in taking the photograph in
the last decades of the 19th century at
the time that photography emerged as the
technique of recording and interpreting
the physical and biological world s
rahman iike hall the father of modern
neuro neurobiology insisted that all his
students take lessons in watercolor
painting and he reasoned haut if our
study is concerned with an object
related to anatomy or natural history
etc observations will be accompanied by
sketching for aside from other
advantages the act of depicting
something disciplines and strengthens
the attention obliging us to cover the
whole of the phenomenon studied and
preventing therefore details from
escaping our attention which are
frequently unnoticed in ordinary
observation without the art of drawing
Natural History and Anatomy would have
been impossible it is not without reason
that all great observers are skillful in
sketching this was the father of modern
neurobiology drawing is a process of
observation and expression receiving and
giving it is always a result of yet
another kind of double perspective a
drawing looks simultaneously outwards
and inverts to the observed or imagined
world
and into the grassman's own persona and
mental world each sketch an drawing
contains a part of the maker and his/her
mental world or in and at the same time
that it represents an object Avista in
the real world every drawing is also an
excavation into the drawers past and
memory John Berger describes this
seminal merging of the object and the
excuse me and the drawer him/herself
quote it is the actual act of drawing
that forces the artist to look at the
object in front of him to dissect it in
his mind mind's eye and put it together
again or if he is drawing from memory
that forces him to dredge him of his own
mind to discover the content of his own
store of past observations this is my
professor sketching at the blackboard
while teaching my class when sketching
an imagined space or an object being
designed the hand is in a direct and
delicate collaboration and interplay
with mental imagery the image arises
simultaneously with an internal mental
image and the sketch mediated by the
hand
it is impossible to know which appeared
first the line on the paper or the
thought or a consciousness of an
intention in a way the image seems to
draw
self through the human hand John Berger
points out this dialectic interaction of
external and internal reality as he
writes every line I draw reforms the
figure on the paper and at the same time
it redraws the image in my mind and what
is more the drawn line redraws the model
because it changes my capacity to
perceive and the quote it is evident
that that the act of drawing mingles
perception memory and one's sense of
self and life a drawing always
represents more than its actual subject
matter every drawing is a testimony a
drawing of a tree shows not a tree but a
tree being looked at within the instant
of the sight of a tree is established a
life experience
growing sorry growing and body imagery
the initial mental image may emerge as a
visual entity but it can also it can as
well be a tactile muscular or bodily
impression or a shapeless feeling that
the hand concretize is in a set of lines
projecting a shape or structure one can
know what one cannot know whether the
image first arose in one's mind and was
then recorded by hand or whether the
image was produced by the hand
independently or whether it emerged as a
result of seamless collaboration of the
hand and the drawers mental space it is
often the act of drawing itself the deep
engagement in the act of unconscious
thinking through making that gives rise
to an image or an idea the second
meaning of the word to draw to pull
points to this essential meaning of the
drawing as a means of pulling out
revealing and concretizing internal
mental images and feelings as much as
recording an external world the hand
feels the invisible and formless
stimulus pulls it into the world of
space and matter and gives it a shape
everything his eye sees he fingers John
Berger comments on the tactility of
Vincent van
Hawks drawings this very act of
fingering the objects of observation or
dreaming intimate or remote gives rise
to the creative process
similarly in the process in the act of
writing it is frequently perhaps even
most often the process of writing itself
that gives birth to unexpected ideas and
an especially fluent and inspired mental
flow it is beyond doubt that the hand
has a central role also in writing but
not only the hand as even writing poetry
or music is an embodied and existential
act this you probably recognize it's any
photograph of Albert Einstein's
blackboard in his study at Princeton
Charles Tomlinson the poet points out
the bodily basis in the practice of
painting and poetry he writes painting
wakes up the hand draws in your sense of
muscular coordination your sense of the
body if if you like poetry also as it
pivots on its stresses as its as it
rides forward over the line endings or
comes to rest at pauses in the line
poetry also brings the whole man into
play and his bodily sense of himself
John Berger gives a poetic description
of the embodied acts internalizations
and projections that he envisions taking
place in fan Hawks drawing process the
gestures come from his hand his wrist
his arm shoulder perhaps even the
muscles in his neck yet the strokes he
makes on paper following currents of
energy which are not
physically he is and which only become
visible when he draws them currents of
energy the energy of a trees growth of a
plant's search for light over branches
need for accommodation with the
neighboring branches of the roots of
thistles and scrubs of the weight of
rocks lodged on a slope of the sunlight
of the attraction of the shade for
whatever is alive and suffers from the
heat of the Mistral from the north which
has fashioned the rock strata I very
much like this powerfully muscular and
embodied description of drawing in
burkas description the muscles and the
artists entire body seem to participate
in the physical act of drawing yet the
act draws its energy from the subject
itself
it is evident that the common
understanding of drawing or painting as
purely visual endeavors is completely
erroneous due to the innate and concrete
speciality of architecture and its
irrefutable embodied and existential
essence a visual understanding of this
art form art form is even more grossly
misleading one who noticed draws a scene
the hand does not attempt to duplicate
or mimic what the eye sees or the mind
conceives
intention perception and the work of the
hand do not exist as separate entities
the sole act of drawing and it's very
physicality and materiality is both the
means and the end drawing is a singular
and inter integrated act in which the
hand sees the eye draws and the mind
cheese the hands want to see the eyes
want to Paris as Goethe remarked or
nothing escapes their great thinking I
think he knows all he sees all his eyes
are in his ears his ears in his eyes
this is Constantin Brancusi describing
his own piece of sculpture entitled
Socrates the artists hand does not only
reproduce the visual appearance of the
object person or event observed
remembered or imagined the hand perfects
the impossible task of creating the
objects very essence its sense of life
in all its sensory and sensual
manifestations the individual
brushstrokes in a portrait of Rembrandt
or an impress impressionist landscape do
not only depict the form color and
illumination of the object the spots of
color texture and light awaken the
object back to life art must give
suddenly all at once the shock of life
the sensation of breeding as param [ __ ]
states in addition to breathing life
into the same the profound work projects
the objects metaphysical essence and in
fact it creates a world quote if a
painter presents us with a field or a
ways of flowers his paintings are
windows which are open on the whole
world as jean-paul Sartre states this
world evoked by a profound piece of art
and architecture is an experience
experientially real world
merleau-ponty points out the
multi-dimensional and monk multi-sensory
nature of the artistic world work as he
writes we see the depth the smoothness
the softness the hardness of objects
says uneven claimed that we see their
order if the painter is to express the
world the arrangement of his colors must
carry with it with it
this indivisible whole or else his
picture is only his picture will only
hint at things and will not give them in
the imperious unity the presence the
unsurpassable plenitude which is for us
the definition of the real that is why
each burst brushstroke must satisfy an
INT
should be in finite number of conditions
each stroke must contain the air the
light the object the composition the
character the outline and the style
expressing what exists is an endless
task yet regardless of the endlessness
or logical impossibility of the of the
drawers tasks the masterpieces of art
and architecture succeed in recreating
not only the existence of singular
objects but the very essence of our
lived world thank you